[موسيقى]
هل تقتل اسرائيل جنودها المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه عمدا لجمع معلومات لاجابه محتمله نعود
بضعه اسابيع الى
الوراء نشرت قوات الاحتلال لقطات مصوره
لجنود من لواء نحال اثناء تنفيذ عمليه على
مشارف جباليا قالت ان الوحدات التقطت
موقعا جغرافيا لنفق اعتقد ان قائدا في
كتائب القسام
يستخدمه قبل يوم واحد من اخبارنا بانه مات
قالوا لنا انه على قيد الحياه بشكل شبه
مؤكد لم يفلح جنود نحال في دخول النفق
فاستدعوا تدخلا
جويا ولكن بعدها بيوم طرقوا بابنا وقالوا
لنا رون قتل على يد حماس انا شخصيا لم اكن
اريد معرفه ظروف مقتله ولكني قلت لنف
اث اطلاق النار
عليه بعدها اعلنوا العثور على جثث ثلاثه
من
الاسرائيليين تتهموا مايان شيرمن قوات
الاحتلال بقتل ابنها مع محتجزين اخرين
بشكل متعمد وباستخدام غازات سامه في
محاوله لاغتيال احد قاده القسام الاشتباه
بوجوده في المكان عينه وهل تقتل اسرائيل
مواطنيها
عمدا هذه مستوطنه
بئيري تظهر صور كاميرات مراقبه سربت بعيد
السابع من اكتوبر قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي
منازل للاشتباه بوجود مقاومين
بداخلها لكن القصف قتل
مستوطنين تعليقا على الجدل للتزايد حول
تورط الجيش فيتل اسرائيليين يقول استاذ
الفلسفه اسا كاشير ان قادته لا يريدون
التحقيق في حالات استخدام محتمله لما يسمى
بروتوكول
هانيبال الذي ضمن توج للجنود باستخدام
القوه لعرقله اختطاف زملاء لهم دون ان
يشكل التدخل تهديدا على حياتهم
اشرف على صياغته عام
86 ثلاثه من كبار قاده الجيش
[تصفيق]
والاستخبارات استاذ الفلسفه هو في الحقيقه
الشخص الذي كتب مدونه سلوك الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينفي وجود اي قانون يتيح قتل
اسرائيلي لاسرائيل اخر تحت اي ذريعه هدنه
مؤقته لمده ثلاثه ايام بين قوات الاحتلال
وفصائل المقاومه تدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد
23 يوما على
الحرب تنفذ مجموعه من لواء جفعات دوريه
استطلاع راجله وترصد وجود
مقاومين يبدا اطلاق النار مع اسناد من
الخطوط الخلفيه قتل اثنان من جنود
الاحتلال واستشهد
مقاوم منظمه العفو الدوليه وثقت احداث
الاول من اغسطس بلسان ضابط من جفعاتي وقد
تكون من المرات النادره التي تقر فيها
اسرائيل وان بشكل غير رسمي بتفعيل
بروتوكول هني
بعل عندما ادرك الضابط المسؤول فقدان احد
الجنود اطلق نداء لا سلكيا من كلمه واحده
هاني بعل بمجرد توجيه الكلمه عبر اللاسلكي
يبدا تطبيق النظام المتبع لهذا البروتوكول
اي ان الجميع يبدون باطلاق النار على
موجات دون توقف وهذا ما قمنا به استمرت
الموجه الاولى ثلاث ساعات وكانت بطاريه
المدافع تطلق النار بالمعدل الاقصى المتاح
وباتجاه مناطق اهله
بالسكان
افتح خام بان هدار جولدن قتل في رفح
واجريت له مراسم تابين ترفض عائلته
التسليم بالروايه الرسميه فكتاب القسام لم
تكشف عن مصيره حتى
اليوم الجندي الميت افضل من الجندي الاسير
يقول ضابط
اسرائيلي